hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast
this is are you garbage it's the show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and find out they grew up classy or if
they're absolute trash i'm your host
stage foley coming at you on a beautiful
day down here
aunt toddy's basement for the holidays
it smells like icy hot and that's the
way we like it
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo
the chairman of the board he's on the
lease here at ayg give it up
for my best pal kippy kevin james ryan
everybody
hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube check it
out those numbers are true to roof
thanks to t-bone over there
uh also patreon.com are you garbage uh
you can guys sign up for bonus content
uh videos bonus episodes every week also
we're gonna be doing a live stream at
the end of every month where we ask you
questions you ask us
questions it's gonna be a [ __ ] hoot
get involved
yes sir i love you buddy okay
and how about a nice big shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the chicago
kid
the [ __ ] magic man we know him by
t-bone around here
toby mcmullen hey
he does not like the new nickname and a
few words over there in the dj booth
i like it but gang we cannot and i
mean cannot got a hot one we got a hot
one we got a little [ __ ]
star power in this dump not the bozos
you usually see on the show yeah
not the animals we dragging off their
streaks that's right our guest today is
an incredibly successful sports
broadcaster reporter
and host of multiple podcasts okay she
has worked as a sideline reporter
for fox sports she's worked at espn the
sec
network espnu of course siriusxm
she is a graduate of texas a m
university and of course one of the
co-hosts of the pro football football
show with deion sanders
and one of the stars over there at bar
stool sports
but the big question but his mind today
is she garbage
i don't know i saw a louis vuitton bag
walk through the door and you called it
a coach man and i called it a coach bag
pretty [ __ ] impressed i'll tell you
that right now give it up for casey
smith everybody
come on thank you for inviting me to the
basement ah
[Laughter]
she is not technically in a basement
thank you for having me so when you when
you run through everywhere i've worked
it sounds like i might be a successful
person you are a successful person come
on
thank you thank you but now i'm at
barcelo sports so you can just erase all
the rest
it just completely negates anything i've
ever done once i go to barstow sports no
way what are your all-class in my book
what are you do you say you're garbage
or not so i
say i'm not garbage but it's usually
because i think my parents aren't
garbage
okay but i think as an adult i might be
a little bit you slipped into some
garbage
well if you talk about my college years
now garbage
baggio so i guess it really depends on
how you guys weigh this
i'm very interested to see how we weigh
this well we found out you know people
that come from like you know decent
families good families
you know maybe wealthy families or so
and once they start making once the kids
start making their own decisions that's
where it really shows that you know
they don't really follow the family
trends you know what i mean they tend to
be pretty garbage
yeah i i like to believe that i've gone
back towards the good trend of my
parents
as i've gotten a little bit older i'm in
my 30s now but i'm going to let you guys
decide that i hear you guys are the
absolute totem pole of who's garbage we
are the authority on trash can owner on
a waste management company
we are interacting well i've talked to
both of you about about leftovers yeah
that was the big thing that i mean that
kind of took that was when it kind of
you know kfc
uh your buddy also from barstool good
friend of ours shout out to the show
shout out to kfc he kind of we the
leftovers debate
took [ __ ] took the internet by storm
for a couple years which is crazy
it's people latch onto that [ __ ] so
easily like we do a radio show every day
on siriusxm together and so we'll be
talking about important things in the
world
not one call we talk about if you should
take leftover shoulder a billion calls
for days and days and i mean it hit and
i got to hear how both of you feel
like if you're on my side yes yes
definitely take leftovers nuts and me
and kfc are on the same side because he
texted me he goes dude you gotta call
into the radio show
we're talking about leftovers and i
don't know to me it's also i'm never in
a position where there is leftovers this
is tired ground we've gone over this a
bunch
but i'm never in a position where there
is leftovers and i don't see how you are
either
this is what this is what i don't
understand i don't wanna have a snack
over there no him
i know i just wanna i just wanna make
sure yes i'm calling him fat for sure
that's a that's a major theme
i purposely that is okay right down the
barrel that's a major
theme this is a pro fat shaming show i
will not be doing that so mark
on the classic
i make sure that we over order a little
bit at the restaurant
especially if i go out to do it with my
girlfriend i know she's not gonna finish
it of course not and that's the best is
finishing her half
at home when we're watching a movie or
something like that you don't even let
her finish it
if she wanted to she could actually stop
that
she wanted to eat the leftovers when you
guys got home would it be she never does
man she
never does she might say hey i'm gonna
take this home and eat it but she never
does
see i actually eat it when i get home or
the next day now it does depend on what
it is i'm not taking bar
food home i don't know sure you're not
going to do like chicken tenders and
mozzarella sticks or something
wait why because it's not good when it's
reheated i think i never reheat a
mozzarella i love a cold mozzarella
stick you know what i've had some cold
mozzarella sticks in my day too but i
i more think of uh take home stuff it's
like steak and mashed potatoes
asparagus like that always tastes good
the next day yeah you can't be heating
up
chicken tenders he will i mean yeah
yeah he's he's he's he's okay i like how
you saw my reaction and bridge that gap
yeah it's okay fatty don't worry
you're gonna have to take home whatever
you want yeah she's like i'm not gonna
eat a cold mozzarella stick you say what
you're not gonna want i start crying how
drunk am i
legally the fourth floor all right so
give us the back story now texas a m i'm
just going to say that's no that's no
slouch of an organization oh thank you
that's a great's a pretty good school
i appreciate it you have to be in the
top 10 percent of your class to get in
there
i um i went to a private high school
non-catholic it was a big catholic
school there was like 300 of us
graduating which in texas is
you know pretty big private school but i
have to tell you we wore the full
catholic school world uniforms
so like you know it was plaid skirts
knee socks the whole thing so i went to
private school my entire life because
like i've said my parents are very
classy suburbs of dallas you said yeah
arlington texas so that's where
the cowboys stadium is now it's right
between dallas and fort worth
um i grew up in an episcopalian school
baptist church catholic high school so
my parents really wanted to [ __ ] me up
yeah they were [ __ ] bad no we were we
went to a baptist uh
church because my dad played guitar at
the baptist church but i
wanted to play basketball so i played
aau and my head coach was the varsity
coach at
the private high school i went to okay
did you follow that yeah yeah
did you get recruited to go there uh no
i wasn't very good but i
most of my aau is good right yeah
usually i was like the last
the last person on the roster i was good
enough to make the team if i got to play
we threw a party when we got okay yes i
am so you were going to private school
no matter what no matter what because
the district that we lived in in
arlington it was right on the edge of a
school that my parents were like
it's a little yeah and then i just
stayed so
yeah so again mark i'm mark this down i
can only see where this can go
now this is the the least garbage thing
i'm about to tell you okay i'm gonna get
it out of the way
all right i grew up playing the harp wow
that thing right there that is me that
is me that's an actual
photo of me my mom
yeah i started playing in kindergarten i
don't think i've ever i don't think
there's any
i've never have one now my parents have
one at their house yes oh your parents
got a little bit of cake no no
no no you got some disposable income
there's no harp in the [ __ ] dollars
but i will say my parents will i know
they're going to listen to this sorry
mom and dad for all the stories
but again i work at [ __ ] barstool so
you already know him anyways shout out
to mr mrs smith yeah they
sorry ron sorry marty so rod and marty
ron and marty smith i know they're
they're great
uh so we the school that i went to like
we
we were upper middle class the school i
went to was like wealthy wealthy yeah
we were like i was like the poor kid you
know i got you i got a honda civic when
i turned 16 thought it was the coolest
thing ever my best friend got a porsche
like so that'll you know
so my parent mom and dad i'm telling the
truth i promise so honda civic's all
right though oh i look
yeah is it 16 year old was it a stick or
an automatic it was automatic i can't
drive
okay i can't drive a stick it's classy
cassie the civic
she had a nice little spoiler
very nice color was it silver yo i've
named
every car i've ever had and that is so
garbage it's
so garbage oh you're naming yourself
like people with mercedes aren't naming
it you know what i mean
you're naming your shitty car to make it
cute and lovable
no one's hopping in their [ __ ] beamer
being like all right ted let's go
but you know what they [ __ ] should
they really [ __ ] [ __ ]
come over here teddy and then but i was
also trying to rebel a little bit
against my catholic school
uh situation i hung a red bandana
from the rear view mirror because i
thought that i was the biggest lil wayne
fan
on the planet oh shout out shout out to
lil wayne yeah so
she's in the south that was probably
kicking down hip-hop pumping oh yeah but
only when i got
away from my parents you know where they
couldn't necessarily hear what i was you
know
i was the same i would turn it down on
my block a little bit
just because i'm a respectable guy you
know what i mean what are you guys from
footloose
they need to have music in your
neighborhood i can't be bumping i mean
we grew up in a cul-de-sac you know what
i mean it's one man in one man out
everybody knows it's me
i would just turn it up a little bit
louder as i get on the highway but
i um uh i i have a younger sister she's
my only sibling she's three years
younger i mean much better person than
me okay she works in non-profit she
works for
an orphanage that helps kids that have
been in really bad situations and i tell
dick jokes on the radio
you can tell who the favorite child is
yeah um what wait i want to go back to
the car real quick okay
did you do anything to like trick it out
did you put like a head unit in it or
speakers or anything or just kind of
stock as is
got it put the bandana on it fake ribs
no fake rims okay no spinning hubcaps
no no no you i don't think you can roll
up to a catholic private school
i don't think that's the 20s rocking i
don't know i don't think that they allow
that they'd be like this like
bumping many men or something father
mahoney what's up
manny man yeah i think that the fathers
and the sisters would have had a problem
with that
um but no what's the deal with this
smith girl break dancing and [ __ ]
yeah yeah and of course the catholic
school it's like you know everybody's
like doing drugs and stuff in the
bathroom
i was too good for that i was kind of
prudish growing up so that was
so that was uh that was my my childhood
now another thing i did grow up going to
a country club
and we would bring home chicken fingers
and reheat them so i do want you to know
that
that's what we were talking about that's
the the duality of man taking
chicken fingers home from your private
country jesus
christ hey they made a mean finger
though the pool the pool chicken fingers
oh i mean come on snack shop dude
my brother belongs to one and we go like
when i go back home in the summer or
whatever
like oh all the kids we're going over to
the pool and dude
they come out in that red and white
little [ __ ] basket
taking me back my my our favorite
dessert my dad's was the uh those
white powdered donuts the you know the
yeah yeah little donuts i can't tell if
you're grossed out by me no i like
no not at all i was like are you judging
me right now are you judging my dad's
favorite dessert no
i'm on board with it i'm saying of
course they would restock them at the
country club for
my sister and i because they knew how
much we loved it was it the sleeve of
the minute
yeah so i don't i don't really know
which way i am right now i can't talk
i'm on the fence too well i mean playing
the harp though has to tip me over the
harps pretty good
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to ask you a series of
questions
to determine whether in fact you are
garbage or not
um we're going to go back to the
beginning we're going to do this one by
the numbers
all right we're going back to the
beginning okay we're going to start off
now you said upper middle class
outside of dallas we're gonna see
what was the name of the street that you
grew up on washington drive
it's pretty classy damn damn
washington heard of him that's pretty
good
i live over on washington yeah wow was
it a cul-de-sac a loop or was it just
like a regular just a street it was a
regular street but my backyard was the
sixth tee box of
the country club so washington drive had
a lot of bag of golf course property
was it the country club that you were a
member of yes so it was one of those
neighborhoods that's a that's a
neighborhood and a country club
well you could be a part of the country
club you didn't immediately get into it
so it's not like a gated community where
you know it was
open open streets um if you wanted to be
a member of the country club you could
also be
wow that's pretty nice now what does
your dad do can i ask you that yeah of
course she's a mortgage banker
a little bit of cage so when i was born
my mom worked for the bank of new york
then she was a stay-at-home mom
with my sister and i then she got her
master's degree
at tcu in art and then now she does a
bunch of charity work
damn you come from [ __ ] congratulations
you're like the kennedy
compared to him compared to him you're
the queen of [ __ ]
charity work she does she she worked for
for a
an older folks home she did some pr she
did go back to work when we were both in
high school because she was like
probably just sick and she was like i
need to probably help
2008 was hard on the family
but uh she she's on and off has worked
in pr and now she's
the coronavirus has kind of kept her at
home but gotcha you know
she did get her master's degree so i
mean that's pretty close
washington drive yeah that's pretty good
hey that's nice around the holidays yeah
it's beautiful i'm sure
beautiful uh growing up i assume you it
was a single family home you had a
garage
we did have a garage in that garage this
is a big big
big hotspot no way this question i know
he's in a [ __ ] yes i know and i bet
you it was stock to the hills did you
have a garage
did you have a refrigerator in that
garage [ __ ] yeah yeah
and what was in that fridge a lot of
soda yeah
a lot of dr pepper down in texas big dr
pepper family big time
is that big in texas or is that was that
you guys just a doctor
i think it's both but like my dad is my
dad's a huge
soda dessert candy guy and he i mean
that thing was stocked full of dr pepper
i don't think i had a coke until like i
went to school like it was dr pepper and
sprite
because we had akash singh who's from
dallas uh comedian comedian buddy of
ours
uh we mentioned mr pibbs to him
and he almost why it's what's the deal
with that what dr pepper's uh i don't
think this is company no i don't know i
think mr pibbs is just super read i
don't think it's
down there is it mr pibb is gross yeah i
don't know he says
i mean that's like [ __ ] i could get on
the street of new york he's dr pepper
the man went to [ __ ] med school
this ain't no [ __ ] mr pibb mr pibb is
like the knockoff
version of dr pepper why is dr pepper so
big in dallas
i actually don't know that answer i
probably should know that answer it is
it's not
because coke's not big in the south it
was cooked it's more pepsi right more
pepsi
yeah but i think dr pepper it might be a
texas company but it's definitely a
southern company because i talk about it
up here and people tell me i'm garbage
for that oh [ __ ] dr pepper i have
that at the holidays
kfc kevin clancy he mocks dr pepper on
the wreck
oh he's trash and some of his cakes are
trash yeah
that's true that's true [ __ ] ice cold
dr pepper
get out of here it just hits so good it
is it was like a treat for us
we wouldn't have it but if we were
somewhere and like you know and like my
brother ordered a dr pepper i'm like oh
this is somebody's birthday you know if
you need a dr pepper you can come down
to ron smith's garage
guarantee you can grab one i love that a
guy who makes some money is
into sweets candy [ __ ] dr pepper oh
yeah sounds like my kind of guy
oh yeah ron smith is a special one what
was the name of the grocery store that
your mother went to or your dad went to
when you were growing up
kroger crow i think that that sound it
sounds harsh but i think that's pretty
much real it's a classy one yeah uh but
it's not like h-e-b
h-e-b is what's happening i've never
even heard of that one oh this kid's
checking the boxes i'm saying that right
now
kroger dr pepper
i'm trying to think of what kroger would
be compared to up here like
um it's not a whole foods it's the kind
of like the next step down
yeah you know new york's taught new
york's very new yorkers you gotta get
into the suburbs to really get a good
glass
it's like wegmans oh wegmans is the
[ __ ] top of the line kroger is like
wegmans
okay a lot of limousines parked out
that you know they call them in dallas
they're thirty thousand dollar
millionaires in their limos going to
kroger
it's a little bit smaller of a of a
wegmans type so
okay h-e-b is the big one down there
that one's like
all the meat in the world that's that's
a true like everything's bigger in texas
but we were we were a kroger family
kroger you walk in you got the bakery
there you got the fresh flowers
yep somebody making sushi yep okay yeah
but not all but not all the time sure
not all the time you know sometimes it
would have been sitting there all day
but we would still get it
tuna's a little bit brown yeah i love i
love supermarket tuna i don't know why i
think you like a lot in the supermarket
yeah kroger it does sound harsh it's not
as harsh as it sounds okay
all right i like it coming up class
so i think i mean really yeah what
kroger dr pepper garage fridge
washington lane come on
i didn't know that a refrigerator in
your garage was classy well
it's i mean it's a must it is actually
we've gone over this a couple times it
is the epitome it's like it is trash
thinking right it's because a lot of
times it's rarely ever you guys actually
might have
that was doing all right rarely new one
usually it's a hammer usually it's a
hand-me-down
it was the old refrigerator yeah it was
my dad's bachelor refrigerator yeah
that's the track mentality of going
well this is big and expensive i can't
throw this out plug it in in the garage
oh yeah it was a
it was the color of that notepad it was
like a little you know it's pretty
trashy
yeah i like it but yes it was it was the
bachelor refrigerator but we still we do
have a newer one there now
okay but as long as it's stocked with
sodas capri suns beers and stuff like
that
that's when you know it's that's garbage
but it's also classy does that make
sense
absolutely yeah i always had his beer in
there actually i got caught with
a 30 pack of keystone light in high
school which is absolute garbage but
that's all
that's all we could afford you know
without asking our parents because my
parents were not on board with buying me
beer
my dad found it in the in my car
and instead of telling me that he did it
he just put it
in the fridge knowing fully well that i
would know he did not buy [ __ ]
keystone lights so then i was grounded
after that but that was his way of
telling me he's like i'm gonna put this
in the fridge and when you go grab your
dr pepper you're gonna see you got
[ __ ] caught so
there's probably still keystone in there
to this day no no chance you drank that
that's uh
how trashy am i uh i was in college or
high school maybe and like
drinking i'm from an irish catholic
[ __ ] family a dirt bag so drinking
was like you know they kind of just
turned their head at 16 a little bit but
i remember i put like a 30 pack or like
i had some leftover beers from the night
before and they were in the garage
fridge and they were milwaukee's best
and natty light and i came home
like two days later and placed up that
was sitting there drinking natty lights
and i'm like what you [ __ ] i'm like
woody and he had never heard of it you
know it's like you know and he goes this
stuff's pretty good
and he's european i'm like what i'm like
dude we didn't even want to drink that
like that's all we could
get our hands on and from then on he
drank natty light
he just changed to drink daddy like
that's trash that is trash
my uncle got heavy in the keystone for
some reason whenever we went to his
house he'd offer you one of those
it'd be about maybe 55 60 degrees not
even cold
and you're trying to suck down a
keystone and [ __ ] keep conversation
going
those cheap beers got to be really cold
if you want to play wow
or just or beer pong that's the reason
we would get in college but i mean you
could get a 30
you know texas is cheap what were the
smith family vacations like
yeah oh boy okay so every summer we went
to a place called south padre island
which is at the bottom of texas beaches
in texas are shitty super shitty gotcha
this one is between texas and mexico so
it's the nicest one you're gonna get
it's still not that nice
but we would go every summer when i was
younger my grandma would come and we
would say for like a month my dad would
go back and forth to work then we got
older
got a little bit more expensive we'd go
for a week one year we went to
maui and my sister and i hated it
because we couldn't boogie board we
wanted to boogie board
now we were talking about traffic yeah
oh yeah so we can't do no body surfing
i was in seventh grade and she was in
fourth grade so we were still in the we
don't give a [ __ ] how expensive these
yeah i don't care how nice the sunset is
right
i want a [ __ ] boogie board i want my
dad to drag our tent down to the sand
and i want to sit in the sun all day
so then we went back to south padre for
the remaining time of me being in high
school that was our big
our big vacation every year it's pretty
classy though but i mean if you look up
south padre island
how old were you when you got your
passport i was a senior in high school
where'd you go that's pretty good to
cozumel for my senior trip
uh-huh yeah all right i had never been
out of the country until then
okay my parents didn't want to take me
out of the country they knew i was happy
in south padre island they didn't want
to spend the money you know
boogie boarding i like it i just
pictured her like standing at the
terminal to get on the plane with their
boogie board
i mean like you missed you're gonna have
to check this you know we would have to
have the thing on the top of the car you
know the
what are those things called the bubbles
garbage right yeah
those things are crashed no the the
thing that like the trunk what were they
yeah
it was an animal wasn't it it was like a
kangaroo or something yes we my dad
would strap that on top of the part for
our boogie boards load up the wolverine
what are you doing you're a [ __ ] you
got a couple of bucks you're a refined
man
you're doing the bubble on the hood oh
yeah we were we had to have the boogie
boards we had to have the
the lawn chairs we'd have the whole
thing and every year we would pack that
well
i would not my dad would pack that [ __ ]
up and we would go to south padre island
the bubbles the bubbles and the bike
rack on the back seeing a family go on
vacation
and that one bike wheels just spinning
real slow you're waiting for it to fall
off and [ __ ] kill you
yeah right through your windshield we
had the bubble at one point on a [ __ ]
plymouth voyager with wood paneling on
it oh hell and i remember it was in the
you're living there dude they grew up in
the i mean we kept it in behind the
house like outside and filled up with
water it was like a pond i'm like mom
what are we i was like seven
being like yo toots clean this the [ __ ]
up that's prime for a bee's nest
yeah no mr smith would hang it above the
cars in the garage
we stored it classy it doesn't look
classy when you're writing down that if
you've got a good garage storage like
the bikes oh and it's organized and
stuff like that smells like wood in
there a little bit he's got a little
little
tool shed or tool bench that's what i
was looking at
super organized still super organized
it's still a [ __ ] garage
how many car garage are we talking about
and you could fit two cars
at all yes shout out to mr smith that's
a [ __ ] proper way to do it and he
had a two but could only fit the one
that's my i feel like that's most
families but my dad my mom's such a [ __ ]
driver
the tennis ball the tennis ball come on
man yeah
we're back and forth depending on i'm
gonna throw you for a gripping episode
this is the i did
i i looked back it was defined by taking
the chicken fingers home from the
country club
like she is left and right she can walk
in both worlds i don't know what's going
on i was driving
driving to school listening to lil wayne
with a red bandana and i was going to
play the harp sometimes at school you
know
i mean i'm an enigma over here were
there any um
water sports vehicles owned by the
family no
no jet skis no but my next-door
neighbors did so we would just use
theirs
you would use theirs with them or you
would borrow them with them okay they
had a lake house
you know about an hour out so we're
gonna go use them any time spent on the
river
any any river river house not until i
got to college
okay oh yeah then i floated the river a
lot
in college ain't nothing better than
putting a cooler in an inner tube and
[ __ ]
jumping in college had a river though
that's pretty cool so it was about an
hour or so away and there's a school
called texas state
people only go there to [ __ ] party
like they can't get into texas they
can't get into a m that's where they're
going but they have a river that flows
through the campus
and they have like three hour floats six
hour floats nine hour floats
you go you have tubes that are coolers
with
speakers on them damn so then you strap
yourselves to each other and you just
get [ __ ] obliterated and that's your
weekend
dude one parent lets their kid go to a
school that has a river running right
now
right i would call my parents and i'd
say hey we're gonna go to san marcos
this weekend and my mom be like oh jesus
christ
i hope you don't die like yeah
we never did it as kids now we did go to
a water park called schlitterbahn
which is yeah yeah oh
it's big garbagio yes um it had the
original park
used river water oh as the
as thing and then my parents got over
like you know we should probably get
some chlorine in the mix so
what the [ __ ] yeah whatever water yeah i
don't it's
it was down the river it was cold as
[ __ ] i'll tell you that but then
we got older i mean i grew up around six
flags over texas and wet and wild so we
had seven passes today
just found out that's what it was it was
six flags was texas right yeah six times
six flags all right awesome we had
season pass with that growing up i had a
funnel
cake every time i went nice so much so
that my first
aim screen name was funnel cakes four
five six oh yeah
man i had some that's bad
yeah that's bad you missed that you're
too old for this i don't even know what
she's talking
about i'm just not in my head to be
polite yeah
screen names were was that instant
messengers yeah yeah
it was just aol yeah and then it was
used to you had to log on to aol and
then they just separated the instant
messenger and when that hit i mean it
was [ __ ] good night
away messages all day long son what does
that mean you were using that in college
to hook up with each other weren't you
guys using that back and forth
yes yeah you were yeah i mean yeah
exactly it was like [ __ ]
you know did you have it on your phone
no no it was
you're so you're at the bar all night
you're all drunk you want to hook up you
have to go back to your room
get on the computer and see who's up i
don't know
i mean i don't know if it was mainly
like a booty it was more like
that's how you created a connection with
somebody like okay
oh he added me on aim or whatever and
you talk hey what are you doing tonight
that kind of thing that you said an away
message
that's kind of vague about a guy or a
girl that you like like if you only
suck my ass or something can you imagine
if we had away messages
it was always like uh song lyrics that
were like
oh yeah it was song lyrics that would
try to talk to the person you were
trying to hook up with or something you
know
actually by the time i got to college
aim was done i
when i had aol and some messenger i was
like seventh and eighth grade so it was
like
and then obviously throughout high
school but you would put the most emo
[ __ ] on your away message like if you
were sad a boy broke your heart you just
fired off abra levine you fired off
ashley simpson
whatever you could yeah and then and
then you started texting i mean
yes am i more than i was bargained for
[ __ ] out of here i was at a [ __ ] frat
party doing keg stands after a football
game
i don't know what you dorks were doing i
can tell you right now i probably had
are you more
by more than you bargained for with like
every other uppercase letter
oh yeah the different fonts all the
different colors and i just might as
well put hey craig why the [ __ ] don't
you like me
pay attention oh my god that was big and
when i shout out to the fallout boys
uh another big one was the lyrics to
grey's anatomy
uh what was that what was the uh what
i've never seen an episode either i
met do i know you i'm pulling things out
of him i know existed
toby do you remember that it was like
raising a friend or something
what was it i think it was the theme
song to grey's anatomy oh and it was
no it was i've never seen it i was just
told it was raising adam
i lost it i had a i'll keep you my dirty
little secret a lot on my away
i wasn't even [ __ ] in high school i
don't know what i was thinking but i
thought it sounded great
wait what was your first the first
concert you ever went to backstreet boys
standard respectable yeah that was the
first one that i
went to on my own volition i don't know
what my parents took me to when i was
younger but i went to the black and blue
tour
for perfection that was that
i mean they still are mine was jack
wagner you probably won't even know jack
wagner is i don't know who that is
he sounds like a bad puppy he was a soap
opera star in the 80s
and mike my cousin loved him what was he
what did he do
he was on general hospital in the 80s
but why was he doing at a concert
he was also a singer he he launched
another career yeah he was he launched
the music
he was on uh melrose place for a little
while if you have to describe his music
career by he was on melrose place for a
while
he was not a singer if you're a social
dude
not a singer yeah you just flat out not
but my cousin wanted to go so they
drugged me because my mom couldn't find
anybody to watch me
it was me and all my high school girl
cousins when i was like 10 years old oh
damn pretty good show
not bad i don't believe you at all
not even for a little bit yeah i mean
how many people were it wasn't at a
stadium
without was that like the valley forge
convention center or something like that
and i remember it was the first time i
cried in front of
uh anybody like as i thought i was
getting older i was 10 years old
and my cousin was obsessed with this guy
so my mom
they were chasing his van through the
parking lot and i started freaking out
because they were driving too fast
because they wanted to find out what
hotel he was staying at wait you were 10
what
your mom was involved in chasing down a
soap opera star at the valley forge
convention center yeah they were talking
about oh yeah
they were trying to catch up to his van
so they knew where he was going your
family is
trash dude i can see if it was like
springsteen or the backstreet boys
you're chasing some guy who's going
to a [ __ ] holiday inn i ruined the
night because i started screaming crying
because i didn't want to get us killed
playing it real cool what were they
going to do with you if they caught up
to him bring it i mean
i don't know what happened hey i'd like
to know hey here's a bag of pretzels
[Laughter]
your mama sure does care about your
concerts boys damn fat boy your mama
sure can drive i'll tell you that
it's a bass player or something no he
was selling merch for sure
yeah that's too funny all right
i got one that's kind of now a little
bit or at all i think we might have
touched about it when we called into the
show
okay uh brush your teeth in the shower
absolutely not
really no all right take care does that
surprise
why why do you brush your teeth in the
shower i mean i do it because i'm
disgusting
most people do it for time management
it's only two minutes it's two minutes
and
my thing is if you're brushing your
teeth you can't be doing anything else
that's not necessarily true get another
set of hands in there
you do have a you don't have an extra
hand i use an electric toothbrush i
don't want to be
shocked you know sonic care what do you
got sonicare yeah hot pink one
okay how often do you change the head on
that thing well it's brand new
so but norm when i had the quip before
because it was a barstool sponsor i
changed it like every three to four
months
damn but that was only because they sent
us they would still watch yeah
what'd you get that free merch they
[ __ ] gouge on those now that i have a
sonicare and i have to take care of it
myself that that'll probably be
like 25 bucks for two of them yeah how
often are you supposed to change them
i don't know my girlfriend's just
stepped in and gotten involved
yeah she just recently went and changed
them because yeah she looked at mine i
had like the toothpaste you can't be
having my wife did the same thing i came
home and there was just a new toothbrush
i was like okay
yeah no taken at least she's taking care
of you guys i know for sure
let's talk to texas a m years you said
that's where it's gonna get a little
dicey that does get a little dicey lay
it on us what do we need to know
sorority no no sports no i worked for
the football team
okay so i was a i wanted to be a sports
broadcaster since i was a kid
okay so crazy that you know what you
wanted to do i'm always baffled by that
that's so cool that's very classy
oh thank you so i uh you know the in
home alone too how kevin mcallister
carries around the talk
boy yeah yeah i had one of those and i
would just talk about football into it
all the time as a kid
and then in eighth grade i said you know
they said in 15 years where are you
going to be and i said i would be an
espn sports broadcaster and i'd be
married with kids
i don't want [ __ ] kids and i don't
want to get married so i failed that one
but i was at espn at that point so
that's cool
at some point i knew what i was doing
but i wanted to go to a
m because my dad went there i didn't
even apply anywhere else like we went to
home games my entire life
about putting it all on red yeah like i
was like this is what i'm doing
um so i went and the only way i could
get into the sports world because i
wasn't good enough to play d1 sports
was to go into like the athletic
training program but i also was not an
athletic trainer like they weren't
letting me so they were like well you
can fill
gatorade bottles if you want i was like
okay so you did that on the sidelines
for texas a m i did
yeah it was amazing so my freshman year
i did that and then
through that i met people in the
athletic department that gave me a job
doing like video producing
and you know graphics on the big screen
and by the time i graduated i was
um doing like tailgate reports and i
thought it was the coolest [ __ ] thing
that's awesome but i mean it was like at
that point i thought it was like the end
all be be-all for me but i
i went to a m solely because i loved it
so much i didn't really have a plan of
how to become a sports broadcaster just
kind of fell in my lap and people along
the way were like she's a fuck-up like
my sophomore year
i think i got so drunk i like passed out
in the the office of the production
center
and my boss at the time was like we're
going to give you one more shot and then
like years later she was like holy [ __ ]
like you really
yeah yeah i just got drunk i took that
one more shot
yeah but no a m greek life is not big at
all so going into a sorority fraternity
is not that big of a deal
i'm impressed working the gatorade
because i played division three football
and that impressed the [ __ ] out of me
the gatorade set up we had was awesome
i can't imagine oh what you had at texas
a m a m is popping
a lot of oil money down there yeah a lot
of oil money i'm surprised it took you
38 minutes to bring up that you played
d3 football though because of that
without even sports related guests
he sneaks it in the first three minutes
which
came up organically what that did which
school uh weidner university
i have no idea where that is fair enough
we're going to cut that out
and need to be back after this neither
did he to be honest with you
sounds great though it was a good time i
love the fact too that you thought
you know to see people succeed in the
field it's like you thought i when you
were doing the tailgate you know remotes
or whatever yeah
this is the end-all be-all and you were
so happy to do it that's how you say you
really wanted to do something well same
thing with hustling i remember like
being like you're gonna pay me a hundred
bucks to drive three hours to do
comedy and you're gonna give me chicken
fingers like [ __ ] hell yeah i want to
do that you know
it's when people like quit when they're
having to do that it's like you didn't
actually really
want to do that so yeah so that uh that
was it was it was a grind but i mean a
m basically when i went to school i
started to rebel against everything that
my parents had wanted me not to do so
started sleeping around
drinking a whole bunch uh and i just i
mean i was just blacked out for like
three years
that's college that's college though i'm
not gonna hold that now
and that doesn't make you yeah yeah
everybody do you still go back there
for like for like homecoming and [ __ ]
like that no i do have
i own a house there so i do i own a
check please
um but college station is is super cheap
i mean it's outside of houston but it's
i
the house that i lived in right after
college because when i was working for
espn i was
based out of college station okay but
like i flew all over the country for
games
nice so i was like well why not just
stay here my boyfriend at the time was
there so i just
i woke up one day in the house i was
living in one of my guy friends owned it
i was like i [ __ ] hate these
decorations and i was like i'm just
gonna buy this house from you
and so i bought it redid it and so i
still own it now but i never go back
damn what'd you do with the dude that
was living there told him to beat it
yeah we did it for six years and then i
moved
to boston and he didn't want to move
with me and i was like well then good
riddance
wait that was the guy that owned the
house no that was a that was a guy
friend that i wanted to buy the house
from but
i i rent it out now but i never go back
to a m i don't usually go back to texas
like the only time i go back is for
christmas
gotcha not i mean you're going for
thanksgiving no i probably like corona
oh yeah but if not you would have went
no so normally we're on the road for
college football
so i don't ever go home for thanksgiving
yeah normally we're working i don't
thinks even to me is not that big of a
deal okay
yeah but no but i i when i i told kevin
and john that i would not tell you guys
this story because i know what this is
going to do to my
garbage drink ship it tweet the deets so
in one of those blackout years of a m
i went to a lil wayne concert oh boy
actually i think it was just laughs
yeah totally get ready to cut and print
this i think marty and ron
go have a smoker go watch her nutcracker
videos from when we were dancing ballet
go check out the garage yeah go tune
that harper will yeah
so uh it i think it actually wasn't just
lil wayne i think it was like all of the
young money labels
oh my god young money cash money baby
this is um this was like one of the
first concerts that i went to that was
outside in college what year is this i'm
sorry
2008 probably the height
yeah 2008 carter three has just dropped
little wayne's my favorite rapper do you
want to get married right now i mean
people say people say he's washed no i i
mean like i said i was listening to the
hot boys like behind my parents back
whenever
like lil wayne became a thing so we went
to this concert and it because it was
outside you know we smoked
joints and i thought it was like the
coolest thing ever so i've never been
able to smoke in public
you can't you can't do that little
wayne's concert it's like yeah
it's a little different talk about fast
and loose with the [ __ ] public
intoxication
i mean just and i i think i was one and
my group of friends i was
there was like i think 15 of us i was
one
of two white kids that went and i'm
blond hair blue eyed you know just
trying to fit in
definitely not fitting in at all
standing out like a sore thumb she's got
the band-aid
i think i was wearing like wayne's face
across my chest and everything but
um i got so high and i was so happy i
was like you know what we need to do
we need to go back to college station
and we need to get tattoos uh
and i told my friends in the car i said
listen
don't talk me out of this like i'm high
i'm drunk do not
tell me you have a little wayne tattoo
almost
almost so i i was just a little weighed
so
your mom ran into yeah you know how to
play the hawk
yeah you danced ballet your whole life
um i
so i went i went to the tattoo parlor
and i mean i was adamant to my friends
like do not [ __ ] stop me from doing
this i want this
and i am not kidding you from my bra
strap down to like right where my jeans
would be
i had young money in cursive stenciled
down my rib cage ready to go ready to go
i'm i'm laying on the table
holy [ __ ] i'm laying on the table and
like i said i was so happy and so high
i was just like this is the best
decision i've ever made in my entire
life
and i'm laying there and the tattoo
artists just and yeah it's college
station texas like they don't give a
[ __ ] they're only tattooing drunk
college kids
yeah and i saw him kind of turn to one
of my girlfriends and turn back and i
was like no one [ __ ] stopped me
and she just was like i'm sorry you're
gonna hate me you can't [ __ ] get this
tattoo you can't do it and i was like
no i'm getting this tattoo and she's
like casey if you still want it tomorrow
we won't wash off the stencil we can
come back and he was like i will do it
tomorrow morning
i woke up the next day and bought her
breakfast
but i kept the stencil out yeah [ __ ]
yeah for a little while but i mean i was
so dead set on it and it was gigantic
i mean all the way down and so when i as
soon as i told that story at marshall
they're like yeah you're [ __ ] trash
i also i also had my tongue pierced at
the time too so i don't know if that
who's that friend that doesn't help
still friends at her yeah i am i am her
name is blair that's pretty good shout
out
shout out to blair shout out to blair
yeah
you know what so does everybody at
barcelona in fact speaking of tattoos in
barcelona
that would that you could be a
completely different person if you got
that tattoo
yes it would have been butterfly effect
i mean just all the way down you would
have been in the lazy river or something
yeah i had that's the t-mobile sidekick
you know and i was clicking away
i had the side kicks oh yeah so trash
i wanted it because lil wayne said call
me when you want [ __ ] call me on my
sidekick
i was like i gotta get a [ __ ] i got a
sidekick for that exact same reason yeah
for sure
and my buddies my buddies would all go
look at kevin call me when you want call
me on my sidekick and you get real mad i
know maybe you didn't i was an angry
texter and i'd flip it around and just
well i had the slide mine pushed off
down i had the one that went straight up
i had like the second generation you had
the poor one
no that was the new one that came out oh
i thought the flip one was the game no
that was the original and then the
sleeker one that came out was the slide
the slide kick as we called it in the
streets i
to check out this little wayne's music
and find out what this gentleman's all
about
yes yeah the kids seem to love them yeah
cool mode you can check out more of a
steve miller band
what was yours what was your general
hospital
got my tongue pierced because of lil
wayne because of like me like a lollipop
jesus i know trash i'm telling you super
trash
i was working for espn for a while
that's classy but yeah that
so now when we talk about tattoos all
the time so actually right when i leave
this studio with you two fine fellas
three fine fellas i'm going back to the
barstool headquarters because
we are getting tattoos from an amateur
tattoo artist tonight
what what why i don't know that's
awesome
so no that's trashy it is well i'm i'm
not going to get a big one i'm going to
get a little tiny smiley face but have
you heard of the show we do called
lowering the bar
yes yeah okay so vibs is giving tattoos
tonight
oh my god it's the worst idea ever john
feidelberg bought
a tattoo gun on amazon i love it
overclocking that guy
you're [ __ ] that guy plays it fast
yes so he
i love him so he's literally my thing he
he's he's my best friend on the planet i
[ __ ] hate him
um he bought it for a hundred dollars
off of amazon i like how he low ball
he went for the cheaper well like he
said it was the most expensive one which
i just do not really want he's got to
make sure that's clean and stuff so
we do have a tattoo artist coming to
make sure we don't kill each other
he's not gonna touch us but uh and john
is apparently getting a cartoon on him
and all these people are getting big
tattoos i think i always want a little
tiny smiley face but
they they were trying to convince me to
get the actual young money tattoo
tonight
i will not do it i will not do it are
you getting the smiley face i haven't
you got why don't you guys decide
no not on my face yeah sure it should be
gotta
feel concealer i mean i'm gonna make it
as small as possible
inside your lip see i would say that
normally too but i don't want an amateur
doing that feels
true but those go away i have the word
[ __ ] tattooed on my body
yeah and ribs are great on the side
because you can cover
you cover it with a bra or whatever
swimsuit will cover it or you can show
it off if you want
it's the best place to do you have [ __ ]
tattooed on you and why are you wearing
bikinis
you're like my babies why didn't we hear
about this in the interview
yes i wouldn't have hired you if i knew
you were inked up like a [ __ ] bacon
you know that's a sin this ain't the
hell's angel's guys i'm jewish for
christ
we run a classy operation uh me and my
buddies used to run a show called
[ __ ] and
okay and my buddy kevin was like i'm
gonna be the first one to get the tattoo
and i got hammered and my roommate did
stick and poke tattoos so i did it just
to [ __ ] my buddy
never get a tattoo from a roommate that
doesn't like you
bad ideas never gonna tattoo i mean
we're doing it just at barcelo's
headquarters which is disgusting in the
first place so
but that mean that is super trashy that
is but they wanted me to get young money
and i just i refuse
you could get like a like a tiny like
ymca i can't even do that
because you know this i mean i feel like
if i do that it's like reversing like
i'll go backwards
i would love to know the sidekick comes
back out
with the super long nails again i would
love to know you you got the tattoo
nails uh for a little bit yeah but just
for a little bit like i think for like a
week because i couldn't do anything and
i play the harp you have to have short
nails
this is crazy i know i think you might
be like the proper coin flip 50 50
garbage class i feel like that i mean
honestly i was hoping for that because
if you were guys like oh no you're
totally garbage like
my parents lied to me my entire life we
did dance uh
in the nutcracker every single year i'm
gonna start trying to make myself classy
here after my young money tattoos wasn't
it was it the nutcracker yeah but
it was like the hip-hop version it was
the crowd it was the dallas fort worth
the chopped and screwed remix of the
nutcracker although that kind of sounds
great yes that's pretty hot um get on it
i actually danced for the the real
ballet company of
dallas fort worth and my my ballet
instructors were from russia they danced
in the bolshoi ballet
so i danced in the nutcracker growing up
every christmas it was at the bass hall
in fort worth you're like an undercover
cop
i know who's in too deep i don't know
who you are anymore i don't know who
she's calling the stars you're gonna
make me get a young money cash money
tattoo you know and so many of these
stories were like buried
deep deep within because when i was
working in network tv you can't say
anything
no you gotta hide it now barcelona
they're like yeah we're gonna tattle
each other's faces
we need know that the most expensive
tattoo gun on
amazon is 700 bucks
for the amazon deal today guarantee you
he was so [ __ ] up he doesn't remember
was getting loose on cyber monday yeah
but he he is
honestly like so i've been to his
family's house at one of their houses in
massachusetts i have no clue how he
turned out the way he did
yeah that's at least you can kind of see
with me there's some sure
you know you still yeah a little bit of
it left with my parents that's nature
versus nurture right there he is
peter carter yeah man
yeah um all right i got i got two for
now okay right
apparently if we were we were gonna go
over to your apartment
right now uh and we asked for some water
what would you give us would it be
out of the sink would it be a brita a
bottle what are we doing i would give
you
a bottle of water because we are
sponsored by body armor
at barcelo sports so i keep that stocked
okay yeah that's pretty good cold
cold is the refrigerator pretty
organized it has to be
okay i'm a little bit ocd when it comes
to that nice i have a very tad bit of
obsessive compulsive disorder when you
eat dinner to eat dinner at home
at the kitchen table or do you eat in
front on the couch in front of the tv
depends on how depressed i am at the
time nice but i have a little breakfast
bar that sometimes i sit at but most of
the time
most the time i sit on my couch but i
have one of those like uh it's not a tv
tray because they
are trash i did have a tv tray growing
up bottle of hot water
as kids you already have tv trays well
we would eat at the kitchen table
unless my parents you know we had
babysitters over or if it was just my
dad my mom was out of town we had the tv
trays out yeah
the meals where you have to like rip the
plastic off the tv like tv dinners yeah
oh yeah
oh really oh yeah when my dad when my
mom was out of town my dad was living
living it up dr pepper's for everybody
breakfast for dinner and [ __ ] like that
oh yeah oh yeah whatever we love the hot
dogs with the cheese in the middle of
the oscar meyer
i was just [ __ ] talking about that
that's what oscar meyer cheese dog
is the epitome of deliciousness it's so
[ __ ] good i had one in the last year
and they still hold up they're [ __ ]
yeah
oh i've had them like an episode of
family ties yeah still okay i throw two
of them in the microwave for
the button at my mom's house is easy
minute good night
see we i liked them boiled growing up
which is pretty gross
grilling them to me i didn't like the
charred sides but i was like [ __ ] that i
now as an adult i like things grilled
but i wanted to boil those babies
what do you think is the trashiest way
to cook a hot dog cause we we've
discussed that on the podcast
i think microwave right microwave okay
yeah you have to like wrap it up in a
paper towel and then
no what i would just put them on paper
plates yeah throw them on a paper plate
no he cooks them in the toaster oven
like a psychopath what that's the only
way to cook a hot dog
you got a toaster oven and you got to
spiralize it
sounds so easy i don't even know how to
do it i've had toaster ovens my whole
entire life that and i've eaten
she doesn't own a toaster probably you
don't know no there's one at barcelo so
i could try it yeah that's
what i'm just saying i've eaten ten
thousand
oscar buyer cheese dogs in my life and
i've made them next to the toaster oven
never once has it crossed my mind to put
it in there how do you spiralize a
[ __ ] hot dog you take a you take a
knife any knife will work
butter knife knife serrated pocket
straight blade whatever you got and you
just you just cut at an angle
not not so deep that you split it but
just you just and you spin the dog
and then when it cooks it kind of
expands a little bit so the you get the
inside crispy and the outside crispy
it's unbelievable total game changer
it's the only way to go that seems like
a waste of time i'll be in the microwave
yeah i'll be done in a minute easy
minute
that's how that's how you make a snack a
meal
[Laughter]
uh all right and then i got one more um
if you could if you're going out and
you're gonna buy a chocolate bar
what kind of chocolate bar are you
buying are you going high-end you're
going well what is it
i like dark chocolate like as dark as
you can possibly get
like 90. like 90.
um i'm not i like the the whole foods
brands like i don't really necessarily
have a brand i'm for sure going to buy
um i'm not a huge candy person okay so
don't take after the old man i see no no
my like when so
we used to pretend like we were going to
give things up for lent yeah
but my dad would always give up soda and
candy and i'd have to give up like
cheese hot dogs and [ __ ] um but just any
dark chocolate really but like
i don't have a specific product yeah is
whole foods your primary supermarket now
trader joe's oh i like it again she's
right there in the middle
it's kind of trashy but it's awesome too
yes like justin's
uh peanut butter cups the dark chocolate
[ __ ] goodness but trader joe's has
like the little miniature ones that come
in the tub
trader joe's i said they kill it on all
fronts because they have [ __ ]
they have pre-made stuff that's not
really pre-made but they do the thinking
for you right exactly
what are you when they're marketing
partners i'm telling you
is that a read this we went to the one
at columbus circle [ __ ] right before
thanksgiving got
all hooked up and it's cheap it's nuts
it's so [ __ ] cheap but you go to like
a dagocinos in the city you're paying
like ten dollars for a boxing series
they get you cut
it's like 14 bucks for pasta at that
place yeah i get you coming and going no
trader joe's
is my go-to i will actually go out of my
way to go to a trader joe's
even you know if i could just go to like
a local store for something i'm like no
i'm going to trader joe's okay
all right let me ask you this do you
sleep now with a fan directly on you
yes you do what kind of fan one of those
well it's across the room though
that's not okay it's not on your face no
no no no so it's directly across from
it's one of those big box fans now not
over the windows
no not a box the the big silver ones the
circular silver ones
like the stand-up ones no it's not a
dyson or anything no no it's down on the
ground but it's like the big one
oh really you have one of those so the
only reason that's like dorm room [ __ ]
the only reason i have one of those is
because so i live in a co-op
and the guy who owns my apartment last
year remember when there was the
blackout and like everything went to
[ __ ]
sure my air conditioning went out and he
lives in france and so instead of having
like somebody come fix my air
conditioning he was like well there's a
blackout people are backed out here's
this [ __ ] fan and i was like are you
serious so i went and stayed with one of
my friends
but then i realized that it actually
puts out a nice amount of air fan's not
too shabby not too shabby so i have it
across my bedroom but i only do that
during the summer and the winter i just
sleep with a window open
yeah who are you you are a mystery
trashy fan
lives in a co-op owned by a guy who
lives in france i don't know
i don't know what to do with that
24-hour doorman too and a pool
rooftop the whole thing you got to do it
but i will say the fan looks nice though
it's not a shitty one
uh-huh it's like one that you know if
it's the one i'm thinking of it's like
something they use for like
high school productions to like make the
snow go or something like that
it's a it's a regular fan but it has
like a little a little hinge on it
yeah it's like it's on the floor yeah
but it's big and it's like silver
yeah yeah but
i didn't bring that with me though that
that was that was gifted by my
owner of my my apartment but yeah it was
kind of a piece of [ __ ] moved i mean it
was like
70 or it was like uh it wasn't like last
july it was really really [ __ ] hot
for a while that was right when it
happened
and he just was like no i'm not going to
fix it for a little bit
who needs them but i do have i do have a
fan though so
what about the pillow situation how many
pillows you rocking when you sleep
uh on my bed i have seven pillows
okay but i sleep with only four on the
bed
okay i have two i have two decorative
pillow or two you know the the front
cover pillows i don't even know what
they're called which
will tell and then a decorative pillow i
take those off at night before i go to
bed what's the sleeping positioning with
the pillows how many behind your head
uh two behind my head and then i like to
like maybe hug one if i'm sleeping by
myself
all right what about one one between
your legs no i like to do the the
comforter between my legs
yeah yeah so just kind of you know twist
around having sheets that are too tight
not fun oh i hate to talk yeah it's like
give me the [ __ ]
two tops one
but i do have buffy pillows if that
helps at all i don't know if you guys
know that's pretty cool that's buffy
buffy it's like uh they're made by like
eucalyptus
instead of like cotton oh i've heard
about that your instagram will have it
yeah i'm talking about it my [ __ ]
wife was telling me about this yeah
i actually i do highly recommend no free
ads but they i have my entire bed my
comfort or everything is them
stunning down comforter yes duvet yes do
you make your bed every day
every single morning wow that's the
first thing
it's a sign that my depression and
anxiety is out of control if my bed is
not made and if my suitcase is not
unpacked that is something i have to do
like as soon as i get home i could be
gone for two months i have to unpack
and then i have to make i mean that's
the first thing that i do when i get up
and i have a gravity blanket too because
you know the anxiety so i even fold that
up nicely on the other side
well how how heavy 15 pounds but i don't
like it on my legs because like i said i
don't like when my legs are restricted
so i place it all right on my chest
unless i have a male friend over then
i'm not sleeping with an anxiety blanket
that would be
wait gravity blanket does what makes you
feel like you're getting a hug no it's
the weighted blanket yeah
yeah i like it on my legs because i get
crazy legs at night
that's all the anxiety comes out my legs
i slept with it last night i told my
wife i said where's the heavy marathon
where's the heavy john i gotta
i got the crazy do you share one with
her it's hers but she doesn't always use
it like you're not both underneath it no
no okay it would just be one question
we have the 30 pound we got the heavy
we're talking heavy bike
we got the 30 pound and i fold it in
half and then i put it on top so it's
all on top of me that's what i do i need
to feel like they're burying me dude yes
that's the only way i can get some shut
eyes
yeah drown me in this blanket too much
coffee
do you do you still booze now oh yeah
when was the last time
you did a keg stand uh this summer
see there we go
i don't know what's going on here this
summer i mean i i mentioned it earlier
and the only reason i keep bringing him
up is because you guys know how trash is
john is my best friend
so i i do party with him quite often but
um we did
we did keg stands and mushrooms over the
summer or one weekend
um i'm a huge beer pong fan love a good
love a good game of beer pong so i get
in that at any point um we used to do
keg stands so that the house that i have
in college station
all of my friends from college would do
a reunion and i have a pool in the
backyard and we would
do keg stand like bull riding yeah you
know we would
we'd empty it out throw it in there and
see who could stand on that sure the keg
standpoint
yeah yeah we've got that supergirl throw
the keg in the pool
and try to ride it try to ride it try to
get underwater cakes danger floating
around
yeah we were too busy taking that [ __ ]
back trying to get that deposit
yeah no okay definitely a keg stand this
summer yeah i'm fantastic at it by the
way
just absolutely fantastic this is a real
this is a real niche one
okay uh you said beer big beer pong big
beer pong three cups left what's your
rack
are you going diamond yeah triangle i
mean triangle two one i'm a triangle man
trash that's stoplight get out of here
but bozo's all class
bozo buckets no no no you do the
triangle and if you have four left i
will do the diamonds
but i always wait to get to the three
yes i agree um also to a new thing that
i was playing with like my cousins who
are like younger like
significantly younger they're probably
like early 20s over the summer and they
do the reverse
tr an upside down triangle what so the
the one is
it's two in the front and one in the
back absolutely not and i'm like they're
like like give me a try
i don't know they're like reverse
triangle like what what is this the
nexus of the universe get out of here
and the diamond als
diamond pure trash you got to go rhombus
on its side bozo
[ __ ] new money [ __ ] get out of
here we're playing [ __ ] street rules
and you go triangle hit the [ __ ]
bricks can you can you finger
and blow you can blow the family
we do girls can blow bounce or obviously
swat
no we don't guys [ __ ] are you guys
talking about
you know that's a sexist thing you know
no goaltending you guys are out of your
[ __ ] mind no
you could you could only you could only
blow the once the ball was in the cup
like you can't blow it before you know
you got to just just the tip for a
second
yeah no we play uh gel you know
jailhouse rules
yeah [ __ ] dude if you're taking a
[ __ ] stoplight
get out of here get out of here toby
you're fired that's it get him his
[ __ ] walking papers
i'm never gonna look at you i guarantee
you we could beat his ass and beer party
let's go
go get a thing of solo cups yeah oh damn
but yes catching
this
he's up at the office right now he's
probably drunk as [ __ ] waiting for his
tattoo
all right you're not supposed to get
[ __ ] tattoos while you're drunk by
the way
because they're bloodstained they're
bloodstaining i know wow he does a lot
of things that are bad for his body
couple more questions here and let you
get out of here okay um
kippy you want to go yeah i got one uh
you're at your local mall it's dinner
time you know maybe not new york but
you know in you know a proper suburban
mall food court
talking food it's dinner time where are
you going
is there a chick-fil-a there is there's
whatever you want in a proper you know
chick-fil-a
love a good chick-fil-a either that or
the chinese food that gives out the free
one strawberry oh
yeah i love that but if i can get
chick-fil-a
in a situation like that that's i'm
gonna do that nine out of ten do you go
to the chick-fil-a in new york
ever no if we get it ordered to the
office i'll eat it but it's just not i'm
i'm not going to go out of my way for it
it doesn't taste the same as it does in
the south oh yeah
i don't always get lunch over there do
they order lunch for you over there no
sometimes oh sometimes every once in a
while we do get a lot of free pizza
because of dave obviously like all the
one bite you know a lot of free pizza
wait you got to start
doing pizzas or something so we got to
get some [ __ ] free from some free zoz
coming in here that was all i ever
wanted to in the entertainment business
work at a place where they where they
got your lunch
that is pretty classic it's real classy
we do have like a great snack bar
for free yeah like bagels and muffins
and stuff no like
[ __ ] cinnabuns and what yeah we got
cinnabons
lots of uh chips and really all the
trash
now you're speaking a big man's language
i don't know you're talking about beer
pong red lights or whatever
now we're talking [ __ ] cinnabon baby
yeah european
we got it we have all that the trashy
snacks at barcelo they're gone
as soon as they're put out because a
bunch of savages but yeah yeah
definitely
have you ever operated a t-shirt gun no
but you know what i want but that would
be occupational so true she wouldn't be
just doing it with her friends
i have shot actual guns yeah really
yeah i grew up you know south you know
ron keeps a piece down at the house
yeah his so his thing was he was always
like if somebody breaks into my house i
can't
uh save my my wife and two daughters if
i don't have an eye unless i got a
little nickel on me yeah i have no clue
where
the gun in the house is i still to this
day do not but my grandfather used to
take us out and shoot on the range i've
never gone hunting or anything like that
but my grandfather used to take us out
so we wouldn't be scared of them so if
we did ever come across them
now i live on the east coast and i'm a
little bit i feel a little bit
differently about that but
yeah yeah yeah you grew up that way
uh-huh i get it no t-shirt gun so i
don't know where the [ __ ] i would have
shot a t-shirt gun that's my last shot i
got nothing else
anything in your house right now say
live laugh love no no tchotchkes
no bean bag chair no you have a rumba
no swiffer yes but i don't i don't use
it very often because somebody cleans my
apartment
damn i was gonna ask you you gotta clean
it you got a cleaning service uh
his name is angel and he's great wow
yeah
that's pretty good yeah
i'm going to say i'm done and i'm going
to say
you're 100 classy that's what i'm saying
right
so honored i'm not saying there's not
blemishes but we all
we all have a past you're not running
for congress or anything like that so
the young money tattoo story didn't
didn't push you over that didn't push me
up
you were close because i didn't get it
you know you have to thank for that yeah
blair blair shout out will she be in the
wedding party if you got married
no she would definitely be invited
though but i don't want to get married
ever okay we haven't stayed in contact
as much i mean we still are friends but
uh
you're like vietnam buddies yeah you
know if we were around each other we
would relive the old times
maybe do a cake stand or something
definitely probably drink a lot of
hypnotic we love
hypnotic penny and hypnotic
incredible hold on i'd like to recant my
statement
but that that was you're too nice that
was in 2009
you say she's trash i'm saying she's got
angels she's got cleaning services i'm
saying
i'm saying she did a cake stand within
the calendar year come on but it was on
vacation
it doesn't matter i was in mexico i
haven't done a keg stand in a calendar
year that's
and i'm garbage what are you doing 50
split down the middle trash class i'll
take that i
don't i don't think we'll ever see one
so sharply
down there dude she takes it you're
right you're right i'm going
fingers 50 50 country club yeah hypnotic
i'm sorry i can't
i mean i had my give me my saratoga
i had i had my tongue pierced four times
in college but i played
weddings with that tongue piercing you
know in my tongue on the harp
on the heart why did you get it done
four times because i kept taking it out
for different reasons and i was like
[ __ ] i want it done again that would be
one of the reasons um
i had a boyfriend that was like and take
that out my mom caught me one time
another time it was a dare and close up
too quick but i would take the little
spacer and put it in and then go play
the harp at weddings and uh
in like a nice ball gown so i mean i
really truly right
shout out to duality get rid of that
[ __ ]
yeah he's a [ __ ] loser it doesn't
matter i'll take a hate you know i'll
take 50 50 50.
i mean this is cr it's crazy it was each
it was a [ __ ] coin flip it was a
flip-flop i felt like i was playing
ping-pong over here you've lived the
life i'll tell you that well thank you i
appreciate that but like i said i'm at
barcelona so if you guys talked to me in
like a year or so i bet that
the trashiness is coming back he had to
hide it from him she got a face tattoo
she looks like post malone next time she
comes off
drinking dr pepper i don't smoke
cigarettes but i'll
smoke a cigarette she's vaping logan
paul or something like that right
damn i love it perfect very funny casey
smith ladies and gentlemen is there
anything you want the folks out there to
know other than uh
your shows and social media yeah well
i'm on a million shows at barcelona so
you just thank you so much uh my social
media my parents named me
all [ __ ] up too it's casey k-a-y-c-e i
was gonna mention that
that's also points too which on which
way casey's
nobody's who supposed casey like that
i've never nobody but i think it's
because
my last name is smith they wanted to
spice it up
casey
casey lee and it's all spelled weird
what do you want from me
we got to run an honest show here i know
i mean there's fans we gotta we gotta
wrap up but
if you say it with a southern accent
it's like casey lee
all spelled all trashy no yeah because
you can also say hey casey lee it's a
[ __ ] diet
soda go go need a doctor pepperoni sold
her harp again
god damn it yeah she uses her heart to
cut cheese
i bet that would be a great thing no my
parents don't have accents at all so it
does just sound normal
but yeah on social casey smith kaycee
smith awesome
so funny buddy thank you so much for
coming so much fun
what do you got to focus on as always
please make sure you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
subscribe there as well
also patreon.comru garbage sign up for
bonus content episodes videos live
streams we'll be playing the game with
you guys
it'll be a [ __ ] hoot at kevin ryan
comedy on all social media
thanks a lot will this be out before
december 10th
oh yeah okay then gang please come out
and see
uncle hank and kippy co-headline soul
joel's comedy
out there in royersford pa we have our
links up in our bios
and uh come see us we're gonna have a
great time yeah we love you we'll see
you next week peace peace